[Music]
Libya's staggering death toll this
Thursday night the scope of the disaster
it has something that we've never seen
before and the measure that could have
helped save lives red flags about a
stabbing suspects released from a
psychiatric hospital Global News obtains
the BC review board's decision and new
details about the man's violent past
a recycling facility Up in Flames the
worried neighbors and the warning to an
entire city
plus the truth is out there the results
of NASA's UFO study and the plan for New
investigations
thank you global national with Donna
Friesen good evening and thanks for
joining us in Libya families are
searching for loved ones and finding
only bodies the rush of water from
collapsed dams ripped away entire
neighborhoods and the number of dead has
now reached a staggering 11
300. this Drone footage shows the force
of the water's destructive path in the
port city of dirna City officials fear
the death toll could reach 20 thousand
one-fifth of that City's population the
UN said today lives could have been
saved had early warning and Emergency
Management Systems function properly in
Libya as Redmond Shannon reports the
concern right now is burying all the
bodies and getting Aid to the survivors
removing bodies from the rubble and mud
one by one
the Mediterranean waves washing many
victims back to shore as Crews remove
piles of debris Aid workers help wounded
survivors almost all of them grieving
this red crescent worker says he
believes the number of deaths is now
above 11
000. the city's mayor fears the final
figure could be almost double that most
of this avoidable according to the
United Nations weather agency if there
would have been a normally operating
meteorological service they could have
issued the warnings and and also the
Emergency Management all three days
would have been able to carry out
evacuation years of conflict have
destroyed most aspects of a proper
functioning government and created added
dangers this ruined City could do
without an exploded ordinance uh mines
Etc
that have been swept away across town
and they are now scattered everywhere
and that is that is a disaster Aid
agencies are doing what they can in the
conditions the spread of disease a
growing threat this area is impoverished
and has been
underfunded for years uh and Libya in
general has been under front for three
years migrants from other parts of
Africa still came to derna for work or
to cross to Europe
This Sudanese man says he knows around
14 families who were swept away after
the dams gave way the destroyed
structures a growing focus of anger
there are reports scheduled maintenance
work on them was never carried out
online libyans are sharing a poem it's
called the rain and its words are
resonating with people particularly now
it includes the passage the rain exposes
the drenched streets the cheating
contractor and the failed State
articulating the anger of libyans who
feel ignored and abandoned Redmond
Shannon Global News London
Morocco's King held a cabinet meeting
today to discuss reconstruction efforts
after the powerful earthquake there
nearly a week ago the Royal Palace says
it will provide shelter and financial
aid up to eighteen thousand dollars for
affected households at least fifty
thousand homes have been damaged many
more destroyed
it has begun in parts of Marrakech that
are popular with tourists but it's a
Monumental task in more remote areas
people are still living in makeshift
tents as Crews dig to recover bodies
eight is trickling in but it's slow
going and not enough about 3 000 people
died when the earthquake hit September
8th
a small island in Italy is being
overwhelmed by thousands of migrants who
have arrived in a flotilla of boats
[Music]
48 Hours about 120 rickety boats arrive
from North Africa carrying 7 000 people
to Italy's southernmost island of
lampedusa that island has a population
of just over six thousand humanitarian
groups are struggling to provide food
and shelter and the Coast Guard is now
relocating some migrants to Sicily
nearly 124 thousand migrants have
reached Italy by sea this year roughly
double the number compared to the same
time last year
Global News has obtained an independent
review board decision about the suspect
in a triple stabbing in Vancouver's
Chinatown the man had been given an
unescorted day pass from a psychiatric
hospital despite a review in April
finding he posed a significant threat to
the public and tonight BC's Premier
launched a formal investigation into the
matter nitu Garcia reports
Vancouver's Chinatown Community is
shaken after three people were stabbed
at a special celebration on Sunday I
went to turn around he missed my back
and then got my got my gun on my arm
very personal yeah we'd worked very hard
to put this Festival on to bring
Community together police said the
suspect was out on an unescorted day
pass from a local Psychiatric Hospital
Blair Evan Donnelly has a history of
knife attacks including in the stabbing
death of his 16 year old daughter in
2006. on Thursday BC's Premier announced
a review led by a former police chief
the core question of how a violent
psychotic individual was released into
Community to attack innocent people is
the question that needs to be answered
Global News has obtained a British
Columbia review board decision from
April citing the board concluded he
continues to meet the threshold of
significant threat it says he was
diagnosed with bipolar affective
disorder the decision also highlights
Donnelly didn't show any apparent signs
of mental deterioration before the Fatal
attack on his daughter the document says
the 2009 incident was abrupt and without
warning it happened after he consumed
cocaine in 2017 he suddenly attacked
another patient in his unit with a
butter knife to me it reads like a a
dire warning letter from medical
professionals within the the hospital
the decision says staff failed to
properly supervise Donnelly when he was
in a program for people reintegrating
into the community in 2021 and 2022.
this is where the BC review board and
this director
failed Donnelly failed the public it
also failed their own medical
professionals and staff so the big
question remains how was Donnelly able
to go on an unescorted leave and how
will the public including the victims of
the weekend stabbings be assured it
won't happen again
Global News Vancouver
prime minister Justin Trudeau has
announced another measure he says will
help tackle the housing crisis the GST
will be removed from the construction of
new rental buildings it's something the
Liberals had promised to do in the past
Mackenzie gray looks at what difference
it could make now in the construction of
apartments and the Liberals political
fortunes
foreign
the liberal caucus publicly United and
for the prime minister's new housing
pitch pleased to announce that we are
going to be removing the federal GST for
the construction of new apartment
buildings and I'm encouraging all
provinces to do the same focusing on new
purpose-built rentals a plan to Spur
Constructors spooked to the sidelines by
high interest rates and drive down
prices we're going to see more
Apartments go up instead of condominiums
that will be rented out or held onto
without somebody living in them and we
tend to see the Department's rent for a
couple hundred bucks less every month
the program is effective immediately but
the impacts will take time this GST cut
on purpose-built rental will build at
least 200 000 purpose-built rentals just
based on the the number of projects that
we've seen delayed due to high interest
rates those apartments will only put a
small dent in the 3.5 million additional
units that Canadian housing and mortgage
Corporation says are needed to restore
affordability we keep incentivizing
regular Canadians to be bidding up the
price of what already has been built and
so we've got to come in and say with
already been built our goal is for those
things to no longer rise the GST rebate
isn't a new idea the Liberals pitched it
back in their 2015 election platform
dropped the proposal in 2017 but have
dusted it back off today in a bid to
claw back the political narrative from
conservative leader Pierre pauliev's
populist and popular housing message
after eight years of Justin Trudeau nine
in ten young people say they will never
be able to afford a home those attacks
have translated into a 15-point
conservative Advantage but fresh housing
proposals could lead to a liberal leap
what the Liberals can do that the
conservatives can't do is they're
they're in government right now so they
can start implementing some policies
right now that can start helping
Canadians the Prime Minister also
announced top grocery store CEOs will be
summoned to Ottawa to explain high
prices and small businesses also got to
break Donna with an extension of the
Canada emergency business account
repayment program okay Mackenzie gray in
London Ontario thanks there's another
increase in E coli cases linked to that
outbreak at Calgary daycares 329 cases
have now been confirmed most of the sick
are children and parents have written an
open letter to the Alberta Premier
Danielle Smith they're asking why they
haven't heard from her Beyond a single
tweet since the outbreak began now is
when we need to know the leadership
albertans voted for will step up the
letter States and it asks what the
government will do to protect its most
vulnerable citizens Alberta's Health
Minister said today a thorough
investigation into the Central Kitchen
of the daycares at the center of the
outbreak is underway but an exact source
of the outbreak still hasn't been
identified
was it the food handling was it to the
food itself was it some lack of
stringent cleanliness there are many
factors that could have played into this
I don't want to speculate we have to let
the inspectors do their job and really
determine what the issue was
the outbreak was officially declared 11
days ago it is one of the worst Food
related E coli outbreaks in Canada
huge plumes of potentially hazardous
smoke clouded the Skies over St John New
Brunswick today as Crews work to contain
a large fire at a scrap yard and
recycling plant in that City's Harbor as
Natalie sturgeon reports people nearby
are being warned to avoid the smoke
foreign
residents watch as a fire rages at the
American Iron and Metal facility the
fire broke out around 1am and Crews have
been battling it for more than 12 hours
Incident Commander and fire chief Kevin
Clifford said the fire is a rooted deep
within a pile of crushed cars but says
it's too early to say how the fire
started I do feel at this point we're
beginning to make progress and probably
up to an hour ago I didn't have that
sense so I think we are beginning to
make progress Flames could be shooting
several hundred meters in the air
Thursday morning with large amounts of
black smoke billowing out of the crushed
pile of cars Public Health says that
plume is likely filled with chemicals
and contaminants and anyone who sees or
smells smoke should shelter in place if
you are elderly and very young and
anyone that's living with cardiovascular
or lung health conditions this is a very
concerning event American Iron and Metal
is a scrap metal recycling facility that
has had issues in the past with large
explosions and two workplace deaths
residents nearby are concerns as homes
are mere meters from the site it seems
pretty big I don't know they keep
seeming to have issues with this place
I'm fully supportive of recycling and
stuff but it is pretty close to a lot of
homes
Andrew Miller says the fact the fire has
been burning for so long worries him
fire chief Kevin Clifford said that fire
may have been burning for several hours
before smoke became noticeable and it
may be until Friday morning before it's
considered contained Global News reached
out to American Iron and Metal for
comment but has yet to hear back Natalie
sturgeon at Global News St John New
Brunswick
a hurricane is heading for New England
and Atlantic Canada and people are
warned to brace for dangerous conditions
on its path right now hurricane Lee is
set to arrive over the maritimes on
Saturday it will approach as a category
one hurricane and heavy rain and wind
gusts of up to 120 kilometers an hour or
forecast hurricane and tropical storm
watches are already in effect in Nova
Scotia and New Brunswick hitting the
brakes on work coming up while unionized
American Auto Workers are poised to go
on strike
thank you
more than 140 000 American Auto Workers
could be on strike as early as midnight
tonight the United Auto Workers Union is
in negotiations with Detroit's big three
automakers four General Motors and
stellantis the workers are demanding
higher wages better job protection and
benefits and all of this is being
closely watched by the Canadian Auto
Workers Union who could take similar job
action next week Eric Sorensen reports
U.S Auto Workers say they're not
bluffing after years of making
concessions and falling behind the cost
of living they're ready to strike within
hours at different plants for the big
three U.S automakers we are preparing to
strike these companies in a way they've
never seen before we're still very far
apart
on our key priorities on wages alone the
UAW wants 40 percent or more over four
years and the union says four GM and
stalantis are offering 17 to 20 percent
in separate negotiations Ford's CEO is
frustrated if there is a strike it won't
be because we didn't put a great deal in
front of them because we have 150 000
U.S workers could be on picket lines we
don't want to break our company but we
also want to be paid for our Fair wages
as U.S employees rev their engines for a
walkout tonight Canadian workers are
idling for their moment that could come
just four days later unifor is targeting
Ford specifically 5700 workers in
Oakville and elsewhere will be in a
strike position early Tuesday the union
wants higher wages improved pension
benefits and job security especially as
the industry transitions increasingly to
making e-vehicles the tone here has been
less strident obviously we're focused on
getting our own agreement here and we
have our own strategy we wouldn't have
selected for it as a Target if we didn't
feel confident about where we could get
to but even a strike just in the U.S
would affect the Auto industry here we
sent a lot of parts to the U.S they sent
a lot of parts to us it's integrated
production line these are Supply chains
and so effects in in the factories in
the U.S will certainly affect the
ability to make cars in Canada and says
waiverman a strike in both countries
would have a much greater impact on the
economy as Auto contracts in the U.S and
Canada expire almost simultaneously for
the first time in a generation Eric
Sorensen Global News Toronto
Hunter Biden the son of American
President Joe Biden has been indicted on
Firearms charges Biden has been charged
with three criminal counts he's accused
of lying about his drug use when he
bought a firearm in October 2018 and for
possessing a gun while he was addicted
to drugs a plea agreement on Biden's tax
and gun charges fell apart in July this
is the first ever indictment of a
sitting U.S President's child
still why women from Canada who joined
Isis rarely face criminal charges
[Music]
the so-called Islamic state is notorious
for its killings and Terror attacks
about 100 Canadians are suspected of
leaving Canada to join Isis around 20 of
them are women many of whom were
captured and put in camps in Syria
several have since been arrested and
brought home a global news investigation
has found unlike their male counterparts
they've rarely faced criminal charges
Jeff Semple explains why
these yazidi refugees arrived in Canada
a few years ago from Iraq where they
faced a genocide from the so-called
Islamic State
hadiya says her husband was beheaded in
front of her she and their daughters
held as slaves they was beating us they
was giving garbage food to us like the
food they they was given to us it was
glass and the food and she says some of
their worst Isis abusers were women the
woman what they did with that is it is
growth actually they worse than the men
it's illegal to leave Canada to support
a terrorist group and dozens of Canadian
men have been charged but so far only
one woman is accused of supporting Isis
women played all kinds of roles in Isis
this National Security Law expert partly
blames gender stereotypes portraying
women as innocent victims the colloquial
term you often use is Chick discount
that women are presumed to be not
capable of engaging in Terrorist
activities and if they do it's because
they've been duped they've been
manipulated this is you know pretty
strong evidence Leah West traveled to
Syria with global news a few years ago
and interviewed Canadian Isis women
following their arrests including
Kimberly Pullman I'm not above my lie at
that time Pullman said she was prepared
to face Justice in Canada she's now
living in BC and challenging a peace
bond which limits her travel and
internet use but no criminal punishment
charges and prosecution of terrorism
offenses is actually a strong deterrent
for future terrorist activity so the
fact that Canada isn't doing that in
this space I think sends the wrong kind
of message the security analyst notes
Germany the US and the UK have
prosecuted dozens of women a lot of our
allies are really leading the way in
Canada I would say is more of a laggard
on this front we are very scared this
yazidi family says they're still
receiving threatening messages from Isis
they're calling on the government to
protect them and prosecute all of their
alleged abusers Jeff sempel Global News
Toronto
explaining the inexplicable Max why NASA
is taking on the hunt for UFOs
maybe they're out there maybe they're
not well now NASA is taking on the case
it's taking the lead in investigating
unidentified anomalous phenomena what we
used to call UFOs as Jackson prosco
explains NASA intends to share
information without fueling speculation
though no one knows what this is
NASA now says it's sure of what it's not
the NASA independent study team did not
find any evidence that UAP have an
extraterrestrial origin
but we don't know what these UAP are
NASA's first report into uaps or
unidentified anomalous phenomena
outlined how the space agency plans to
investigate the unknown appointing its
first ever UAP research director to look
into hundreds of sightings UAP a one of
a planet's greatest Mysteries
just this week Mexican officials held
their own UAP hearing displaying the
alleged remains of two ancient
non-humans that's above special well in
July in Washington there were
Blockbuster claims of a secret
government program to recover alien uaps
biologics came with some of these
recoveries non-human and that was the
assessment alas there's no hard proof we
want to shift the conversation about
uaps from sensationalism to science
they've already made up their mind
basically with regard to this issue and
that is it's a little disturbing to us
Believers and alien visitors are some of
NASA's biggest Skeptics the agency won't
release the name of its new UAP research
director adding Rocket Fuel to claims of
a cover-up it's really instructive that
NASA has chosen to protect these people
not from being harassed or whatever but
from relieving themselves of the truth
if the truth is out there NASA promises
it will make it public regardless of
whether the answers come from this world
or another one
Jackson prosco Global News Washington
and that is global national for this
Thursday I'm Donna Friesen tonight here
in Canada is Emerald Lake in Yoho
National Park BC thanks for watching
para Nasser will be at the anchor desk
tomorrow and I will see you again on
Monday bye-bye
[Music]